Republicans in 2023 and the American
right-wing movement is fundamentally
about we are the victims and about
grievances even though the right loves
to say all these leftists are constantly
making themselves the victims be it of
racial bias or gender bias or whatever
the case may be it is actually we on the
right who are truly the victims and one
of the big Avenues during which they've
through which they've claimed this
victim victimhood is through big Tech
Twitter is de-prioritizing our content
um uh ideas that are simply questioning
the status quo and conventional wisdom
of covet vaccines are being shut down
and we are being silenced and blah blah
blah blah and even though they love to
say these left Wingers got to stop with
the Grievances and with the word we are
the victims it is really the right that
has played that card and the most
interesting aspect of it is that every
time it's been tested
every time it's been investigated every
time it's been looked into in some
detail it turns out that it is actually
not true Republicans latest ridiculous
claim is against Google and it is a
claim of bias and it has been debunked
they tried to say that Google spam
filters in Gmail were biased against
conservatives the idea was the spam
filter is not merely making a a an
impartial analysis of what should be
redirected to your spam folder it is
using partisanship whereas repub wherein
Republican fundraising emails are much
more likely to end up in spam than
Democratic fundraising emails emails
from the RNC
are much more likely to end up in spam
than emails from the DNC and it has now
been studied by the FEC and the
determination that's been made is that's
just not the case and of course the
right is outraged the right says that
the analysis itself is biased but the
truth is that whenever these things are
looked into we are unable to find
evidence of bias in the investigation
and the investigation is unable to find
evidence of bias in the underlying
phenomena which they are looking at the
FEC looked into it and determined that
it was not true now this is not actually
surprising and it's not surprising in
two different ways it's not surprising
when it comes to the RNC
and it's not surprising when it comes to
Google and I'll deal with each of those
aspects one by one the RNC and the
Republican party and right Wingers and
Maga you know whatever all of them they
have been grasping at straws trying to
prove big Tech has a liberal bias and
the truth is that that has not been
determined to be the case when you
looked at I mean just go through it one
by one when there was an analysis done
of Twitter it turned out that that was
not the case if you by the way now that
Elon Musk has taken over Twitter there's
this new thing called the for you feed
it's basically a sort of algorithmically
curated feed not based on it's not the
the people you follow
it's sort of like a stuff you might be
interested in it's just right-wing trash
I went on there and it was Carrie Lake
anti-vax coveted skeptical stuff uh uh
the the left is censoring what about
whoa good anti-woke anti-trans it was
crazy okay so Twitter wasn't found to be
the case especially not now under Elon
Musk leadership it's become a right-wing
uh platform Facebook well supposedly
Facebook is very much biased against the
right they so they claimed then an
analysis was done every single week
including leading up to the election
after the election well before the the
elections 2020 2022 the best performing
content on Facebook is almost
exclusively right-wing content Dan
bongino Ben Shapiro all these types of
people every once in a while there's a
um Rachel Maddow clip that makes it in
there the top stuff on Facebook is right
wing stuff
now Gmail okay
um so it's not surprising and this idea
that there's just constant liberal bias
in all big Tech has been disproven time
and time again the RNC made the claims
about Twitter before Elon Musk bought it
it was dismissed Etc now
um there's another aspect to this
Republicans are trying to make
campaigning against big Tech a big part
of their election strategy because again
they are the party of victimhood they
are the the grievance politics people
and it may still work like it doesn't
actually matter if they can keep
campaigning on big Tech is biased
against us it might still be useful to
them but then we get to the Google part
listen
I am no generic defender of Google I
mean I just in the same way that I'm no
generic defender of any platform but
having spam filters that are biased
against conservatives would not be in
Google's interests in any way Google is
a business its primary goal is to make
money and alienating a large segment of
the population through such partisan
spam filtering or even if it's not overt
but if campaigns don't convert
and these right Wingers start to realize
it's Gmail that's preventing the
campaigns from converting by sending our
emails into spam it wouldn't be good for
Google's business it wouldn't be good
for Gmail's business so there's really
no reason that they would do it uh and
so it doesn't make sense on any level
and it's time I hope for the RNC to move
on from these conspiracy theories and
from the Grievances and from the
victimization focus on real issues there
are things you could do
as the Republican party to maybe
actually convince some people to vote
for you based on based on good ideas
rather than just more Grievances and
more complaining and more whining but
once again it's been studied it's been
debunked and of course they will say the
study itself was biased